Irish had the entire Island to
themselves but the British were starting
an Empire and well the Irish lost their
tips but eventually everybody comes to
an accommodation except the Palestinians
are you a flipping clown are you stupid
are you
idiotic defend against a rapid spread of
microplasma pneumonia AKA white lung
disease using black resins cogit packed
with immune boosting properties cogit
has been scientifically proven to
promote respiratory Health aiding in
oxygen absorption while also making the
body infection resistant strengthen your
family's immune system ahead of the new
outbreak this winter get your cic today
links in the description box
below brothers and sisters and dear
friends we're going to be reacting to an
absolute Shameless liar an individual
who has double stands and hypocrisy who
doesn't value the lives of Palestinians
or Muslims for that matter
here's a video of Bill Mah whatever his
name is I would like to call him a p
animous which befits him better let's
react to this coward statements let's
see what he has to say you know let's
see what he has to offer us Irish had
the entire Island to themselves but the
British were starting an Empire and well
the Irish lost their tip they blew each
other up over it for 30 years but
eventually everybody comes to an
accommodation except the Palestinians
things change countries boundaries
Empires history is brutal and humans are
not good people history is sad and full
of wrongs but you can't make them
unhappen because a paraglider isn't a
time
machine people get moved and yes col so
let's use this idiot this guy is an
absolute idiotic individual let's use
his arguments so imagine bill I come to
your house and before I come and say and
you open the door and you say what do
you guys want and we with guns and
weapons I'm like listen bad things
happen in life there are evil people
like me and my friends and they come and
take over other people's houses and they
kidnap your children and then they shoot
your wife and they put you in the
basement and they tell you you can live
there and we'll serve you dog food these
kind of things happen in life bill
there's bad people there's evil things
that happen so you don't need to fight
there's no point in fighting why you
going to fight and resist for no no no
no no just accept your fate accept it so
we're going to come in now my men behind
me are going to kidnap your son take
away your daughter kill your wife and
we're going to take you as a captive and
you're going to live in the basement
with the dogs yes just because we care
about you but don't you dare fight
resist be upset about it talk against it
embrace it fully embrace it and say you
know what do yoga yoga and say yes you
know what I embrace my uh Destiny and
just accept it are you a flipping clown
are you stupid are you idiotic what kind
of an individual you are you anyone for
that matter is going to resist and you
yourself forget your house if the Muslim
armies was to come to the United States
or any army Russia for example and was
taking over land what would you do and
let's forget Muslim armies in Russia for
a second let's say Israel I don't know
where you live let's say you live in
Florida let's say Israel came and said
this land is promised to us in our holy
lands in our holy scriptures we are
taking over and they slowly slowly kick
out Americans from their land do you
think America will be as welcome as they
are to what Israel is doing to the
Palestinians no they won't they will not
only resist they would resist of the
idea if Israel made an announcement and
said we are taking over Florida and you
guys are going to be kicked out it's
going to be an apartheid state we'll
commit genocide here and there La the
lowering the mour here and there yeah
just to keep you guys in check we're
going to be doing this kidnapping your
kids all this kind of stuff don't resist
do you really believe any human being on
planet Earth should go and submit to
this kind of requirements never they
would resist and they have damn right re
they have the damn right to resist and
the UN has clearly said any Nation
that's been occupied by the occupiers
has a right to Armed defense yes armed
resistance they have that right it's as
simple as that so the Palestinians have
a right to resist so the point is what
you double standard hypocrite be just
but you can't be because the prophet
Muhammad peace upon him told us a day
will come Liars like you yes Liars like
you would come up a person who tells the
truth will be seen as a liar and the one
who sees says a lie will be seen as
that's telling the truth but Bill a day
is going to come when your soul is going
to be taken out your body and if you
haven't repented the following things
are going to be uttered to you by the
Angels come out to the wrath of your
lord and that day is a day you will
never ever forget for the rest of your
life not the life of this life of the
Hereafter shame on you you double
standard hypocrite if pales was to do
the same thing to the Israelis the whole
entire world would lose their mind it
just shows you like Allah tells us in
the Quran you guys are nothing but
allies to one another you do not care
about the Muslim or the Palestinian
blood but alhamdulillah there are
amazing non-muslims out there who've
head to the streets who've started
petitions who've done all kinds of
things to help the Palestinians there
are goodness and goodness in them may
Allah subhana wa ta'ala bless them and
guide them to Islam till next
time brothers and sisters do not forget
inshallah there is a link in the
description box for a w that we are
building to buy a property that's going
to generate income for Gaza and the
people of Palestinians in and activism
please donate the link below asalam
Alay brothers and sisters and dear
friends do you want Palestine to be free
do you want Justice to Prevail do you
guys want to rebuild Gaza and do you
want to feed those people Po in Gaza I
do and I know you do brothers and
sisters I have come together with a
charity who is inshah getting involved
in building a w what is an W brothers
and sisters just imagine for a second
that you give1 in donation and that £10
is used to buy food or bricks or
whatever to help the people in Gaza but
then just imagine this amazing deed that
you want to do but we turn it into a
money-making machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and everything that
is generated is going to go towards
advocacy it's going to go towards insh
freeing Palestine it's going to go
towards feeding those people who are in
need and rebuilding Gaza brothers and
sisters invest in this walk for now and
let your charity be a true form of SAR
that is going to carry on and not a one
of donation that you give and it goes to
the place of need but rather investing
it's like you're getting a share of this
property and every single time the money
generated from that W that building is
going to go to our Palestinian brothers
and sisters for the next 20 30 40 50 60
100 150 years brothers and sisters may
Allah bless the ones who came up with
this idea I am fully on board and I
myself will be donating for that
inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana tala bless and
preserve you guys we will together
inshallah
see the day when Palestine will be
free